130 milliarden euro jahresumsatz
verzeichnet die deutsche
veranstaltungsbranche normalerweise doch
der korona pandemie sieht in diesem jahr
natürlich alles anders aus jetzt schlägt
sie alarm
heute gibt es eine großdemo hier in
berlin und vor ort ist mein kollege
peter wilke mir nun zugeschaltet wird er
wer genau geht er heute auf die straßen
vor allem wie viele menschen sind das in
berlin
das bündnis alarmstufe rot auf die
straße um für mehr hilfe für die
veranstaltungswirtschaft zu
demonstrieren das bündnis hat klar
gesagt sie sind nicht gegen die
hygienemaßnahmen zum corona schutz aber
sie wollen eben mehr finanzielle hilfe
um durch diese krise zu kommen wir sehen
hier verschiedene schilder auf denen
steht verhindert die pleitewelle als
existenzielle angst bei den
veranstaltern und dieses bündnis wird
präsidiert nach eigenen angaben über
250.000 angestellt
dahinter stehen und für die
veranstaltung hat das bündnis 5000
teilnehmer angemeldet hatte die rechnen
mit 5000 teilnehmern
wir stehen hier am alexanderplatz direkt
in berlin wo sich ein teil der
versammlung hier startet wir können das
im hintergrund sehen da sind auf jeden
fall schon mehrere tausend menschen hier
am platz ob das ganze 5000 sind ist noch
unsicher die polizei noch keine angaben
gemacht zu den genauen teilnehmerzahlen
die das bündnis kommt marschiert von
zwei seiten durch berlin einmal hier
komm' alexanderplatz in richtung
brandenburger tor und außerdem startet
noch vom olympischen platz im westen der
stadt ein autokorso
was genau ist denn heute durch gerade
gesagt aus zwei richtungen ziehen die
menschen jetzt durch die stadt gibt es
sonst noch andere dinge die geplant sind
sind vielleicht auch bekannte gesichter
der unterhaltungs und
veranstaltungsbranche heute in berlin
dabei genau also die demonstrierenden
ziehen einmal von hier aus zu fuß zum
brandenburger tor dann ziehen sie auch
immer noch im auto kurse von dem
olympischen platz aus dem westen der
stadt vorher wollen sie vor dem
reichstag dass ihr letztes hemd
wortwörtlich also das ist ein bisschen
ein wortspiel aus aber sie haben alle
hier ein t shirt ein letztes hemd
mitgenommen wollen sie vor dem reichstag
ablegen um zu zeigen wir sind fast am
ende es ist wirklich alarmstufe rot wir
brauchen dringend hilfe und wollen da
auch mit politikern in den call in
kontakt treten in die diskussion kommen
die man da helfen kann das sind
politiker herzlich zu eingeladen deshalb
auch vor dem reichstag der stopp der
politiker kommen werden ist noch unklar
und ja auch bekannte gesichter aus der
veranstaltungswirtschaft sind hier bei
der demonstration unterwegs wir konnten
gerade mit den beiden musikern von
bosshoss sprechen
uns muss es andere leute jetzt sein wenn
es geht hier um unsere branche und den
das scheint auch auf 50 zukunft wichtig
egal also der gesamte light novel
kulturevent widerlegen betroffen
berufs haben wir uns dann wenigstens
passiert ist ist ja kein ende in
betrieben mit einmal hand anlegen
bis anhin sind dann hat man da macht es
geht ja nicht so und wir sind stärker
treten die künstler ähnlich geht aber
internet
davon werden
müssen uns bei uns werden dass in diesem
fall an die 30 die haben sie alle wären
jetzt eine person und keine
unterstützung des ersten tages und
selbstständige einzelner unternehmer
sind freelancern zu sagen und so die
kleiner hilfswerk sozusagen aus
[Musik]